[Music]
[Applause]
inside the 40
[Applause]
oh that's so pretty that is the
Washington Huskies zooming by Rutgers
last night the 9th ranked Huskies
started the season with a 32 14 victory
they're one of the 4 teams to make it to
the college football playoffs last
season college football's hoping to kick
off where it left off last season when
the Clemson Tigers capped off a
championship season with literally a
last-second victory over Alabama but
like so many other aspects of life right
now our akane harvey is having an effect
on opening weekend earlier this week the
University of Houston's opener was
postponed and tonight's game between LSU
and BYU had to be moved from Houston to
New Orleans here to talk about the new
season is Brian Jones who played at the
University of Texas before the NFL he's
our high-octane CBS good morning good
morning Anthony and Miss Dana it's an
understatement attach that to your name
permanently
first time I have to ask you I know you
have close family in Houston yeah
everyone's fine lost some property but
we can replace that no loss of life so I
am thankful about that but getting a
blow-by-blow drop by drop account of
what was going on there it was harrowing
to watch dad the videos and listen to
people you're panicking on the phone you
got boats pulling up to the houses to
feel back your weight they're just a
surreal situation it's the best word to
use to describe it we'll move on to the
college football season ahead so we
mentioned the Clemson win it was such a
great way to finish the season what's
the overall picture look like this well
I think Clemson will be back in the
picture but I think Florida say this is
their year out of the ACC but Clemson is
gonna still make some noise they have a
dynamite defense coming back the
epicenter of college football still
lives there in Tuscaloosa Alabama they
own college football I still believe
that even though they lost in the last
seconds there versus Clemson you have to
still run through Tuscaloosa if you're
gonna get to a championship ACC edging
over the SEC everyone's talking about
the bowl records and I think that's a
misnomer because it's so disjointed at
the end of the season the college
football season some guys have a week to
prepare for a ball others have a month
to prepare for a ball but the ACC they
did win a ton of bowl games a season ago
so they're now they think they have the
bragging rights as the
best conference in college football we
will see that they've got a good case to
make I think Miami is gonna be for real
finally we can believe in what Mark
Richt is building there his second year
at the helm and his alma mater so
they've got some dynamite teams but
Clemson is ranked fifth do you think
they still are sort of a contender I
know they are contended there definitely
be a continuum I just like Florida State
a little bit more this season they broke
they're gonna break in a new quarterback
there Kelly Bryant is gonna take over
for DeSean watching who's there in
Houston now but they've got so much on
defense on Lawrence and then they've got
to Kristin Wilkins watch this guy man he
can dance like James Brown but he got
about 295 pounds he's phenomenal so they
recruited well
Dabo has won as many games as Nick Saban
has over the last eight or nine years so
they're not going anywhere I just like
with Jimbo Fisher's working with and
we're gonna find out a lot about Florida
State this evening when they take on big
bad Alabama and in Alabama losing a lot
of pieces on the defensive side of the
ball but we know what they do there they
just erase and replace never too early
to talk Heisman who are some of the
early frontrunners well my top three
rightness we said Baker Mayfield I hate
to say this as a longhorn but Baker
Mayfield there's Oklahoma for the
Oklahoma Sooners he's fantastic the last
two years he's finishing top five in
voting sake want Barclays another guy
like at Penn State they're taking on
Akron today in Akron last year they
allowed about 224 per game on the ground
and so look for him to not play the
entire game but I think he's they're
going to be a guy to focus on specialist
they got the balance on offense and and
sound Arnold now I must say I'm gonna
drop my producer in the grease bin to
veto I had James Washington from
Oklahoma State the outstanding receiver
there look what I'm saying he showed up
and showed out the other night and their
ball game versus toasted but he had some
sports hernia and he still blew by
everybody and that toaster hurricane
defensive backfield I took him off my
Heiser list because of the sports hernia
I may have to put him back on their long
season so do you think your four playoff
teams are gonna be are you gonna dog
because you do this every year
you go back and show me to be keep the
tag that was last year we're not talking
about lies we're talking about this year
okay I've got all burned they finally
have a quarterback and believe they can
believe in since you don't Nick Mars so
and can't move down yeah right there
remember lesson don't believe there
quarterback's couldn't hit a bull in the
backside with a palm full of rice
Florida State I like them Penn State
tres McSorely remember no one picked
Penn State to win the Big Ten laughter I
think they repeat as Big Ten champions
and then I say the Sooners did I mention
as soon as twice that's three times
they've mentioned
welcome judge thanks reminder CBS Sports
Network has a doubleheader today
including Kentucky and Southern Miss and
next Saturday cats Brian is the SEC on
CBS kicks off their season-long slate
TCU heads to Fayetteville to take on the
Arkansas Razorbacks the action starts at
3 p.m. with college football today